herzlich willkommen bei zf heute live es
gibt neuigkeiten von der stiko der
ständigen impfkommission zum einen gibt
sie grünes licht für den neuen kroner
impfstoff nowaks für alle erwachsenen
zum anderen bevor befürwortet die stiko
den zweiten booster also die vierte
impfung für besonders stark gefährdete
gruppen das heißt ab 70 und beschäftigte
im gesundheits und pflegebereich
was ist davon zu halten kann oder wachs
skeptiker überzeugen und was
unterscheidet ihn von bayer und tech und
den anderen impfstoffen und wie genau
funktioniert er darüber wollen wir reden
wir wollen auch eure meinung wissen wie
immer hier im chat oder unter dieser
eingeblendeten adresse unter zdf heute -
live at zdf de reden wir mit der stiko
und sie ist mit zugeschaltet in person
von frau professor
ewers sie ist mitglied der stiko und
direktorin des instituts für
allgemeinmedizin an der uni in göttingen
einen schönen guten abend
überzeugt sind sie von nowaks
ich bin überzeugt davon dass ist nach
allem was wir darüber wissen ein gut
wirksamer impfstoff der geeignet ist
zur info gegen kuwait 19 und zur
verhinderung einer erkrankung von daher
ist es gut dass der in kürze verfügbar
sein wird und dass damit einfach noch
eine andere option gibt
nowaks wird ab 21 februar in deutschland
ausgeliefert was versprechen sie sich
von dem impfstoff was kann er was die
anderen nicht können
vielleicht menschen überzeugen die den
anderen impfstoffen die ja als irgendwo
neuartig oft empfunden wurden und die
manche menschen verunsichert haben
überzeugen sich jetzt doch impfen zu
lassen
er ist ja bitte in der wirksamkeit kann
er weitgehend dasselbe wie die anderen
auch aber er ist vielleicht jetzt
einfach eine option für menschen die
vorher
gehen wir gleich noch genauer darauf ein
auch wie er funktioniert aber erst mal
sozusagen die fakten drum um sie
empfehlen ihn für erwachsene ab 18 ist
auch denkbar dass sie das bald erweitern
im moment ist er für kinder und
jugendliche nicht zugelassen
das müsste man sicherlich abwarten da
laufen studien zu von daher wäre das
denkbar aber ich kann im moment nicht
sagen erstens waren diese studien
abgeschlossen sein werden zweitens waren
eine zulassung dann auch für die
jüngeren altersgruppen erfolgt und
drittens eben auch nicht wie die stücke
das bewerten würde da wir im moment auch
gar keine daten zu und sie empfehlen
ihnen ausdrücklich auch nicht für
stillende und schwangere was muss man
zur dosierung wissen
die grundimmunisierung besteht in zwei
dosen im abstand von mindestens drei
wochen gegeben werden können
das heißt mindestens drei wochen oder er
mehr oder es gab ja auch bei den anderen
impfstoffen immer wieder mal die frage
wie ist sozusagen die beste mischung
weiß man da schon genug oder ist dass
das was momentan vorgegeben wird da
dürfte dasselbe sein wie bei impfungen
generell wenn man einen guten schutz
aufbauen möchte dann braucht man zwei
impfungen und in der aktuellen situation
ist es sicherlich sinnvoll die so
schnell wie es möglich ist dann
hintereinander zu machen damit eben der
schutz auch da ist und das ist dieser
abstand von drei wochen wenn aus
irgendeinem grund der abstand größer
wird ist das per se erst mal nicht
schlimm das beeinträchtigt die impfung
die quatsch die wirkung der impfung
nicht negativ vielleicht sogar eher
positiv aber es dauert eben länger bis
ein ordentlicher schutz vorhanden ist
wir schauen mal was hier im chat schon
an ersten fragen kommt die evag wie
youtube ist der schutz von noah wachsen
nicht völlig ungeeignet gegen omikron
man weiß in der tat noch nicht so sehr
viel über den schutz gegen omikron aber
es gibt keinen grund anzunehmen
dass er nicht naja in ähnlicher weise
gegeben sein sollte wie bei den anderen
impfstoffen auch weil auch mubaraks
enthält die anderen probieren nowaks
enthält das protein das ausbrüten virus
und die immunität die dagegen erzeugt
wird bietet eben ja bei den anderen
impfstoffen auch durchaus einen gewissen
schutz gegen omikron
das wird hier aller voraussicht nach und
auf der dünnen datenlage die man dazu
hat ähnlich sein
mayrose fragt über youtube wie steht es
mit kreuz impfungen
kreuz informiert sind jetzt gemeint
vermutlich mit dem einen impfstoff
angefangen haben und mit dem anderen
impfstoff weitermachen und einer davon
wahrscheinlich nur wachsen ebenso ist
das gemeint
es gibt keinen grund anzunehmen warum
das nicht funktionieren sollte auch das
ist ja etwas was in studien oft erst
nach geordnet mal ausprobiert wird die
hersteller selber waffen das nahe
liegenden gründen nicht aber das ist
sicherlich etwas möglich sein wird und
noch eine frage die auch in diese
richtung abzielt werden denn dann wenn
man sozusagen mit nowaks eine
grundimmunisierung hat dann dazu
übergehen dann booster impfungen dann
doch mit mrsa impfstoffen durchzuführen
das müssen wir erst mal abwarten ist
wird eigentlich damit gerechnet dass
irgendwann auch eine zulassung für einen
no wax auffrischimpfungen kommt auch da
die
zulassungsstudien laufen weiter sodass
wird weitergeführt und es ist an sich
damit zu rechnen dass die firma darauf
nachlegt und eine zulassung erweitert
wer nicht ist oder in jedem fall ist das
poster mit anderen stoffen auch eine
option aber ich denke mal für menschen
die das nicht möchten wird wenn wir dann
überhaupt so weit sind auch ein muster
mit diesem impfstoff möglich sein würde
ich sehr stark von ausreden ich sag mal
und so verstehe ich diese fragen und
lässt dass daraus die skepsis nach dem
motto es mag ja sein dass ich jetzt
vielleicht mit nova wachs anfangen aber
landet am ende dann doch bei montech und
anderen weil ich es irgendwie muss durch
durch postern oder sehen sie das oder
gibt es sozusagen dieser annahme gar
nicht dass man sagen muss am ende landet
die ehe jeder irgendwie bei den
impfstoffen ist es eine aussagen ein no
wax ist eine alternative die für sich
allein trägt wie gesagt bisher ist der
impfstoff für die auffrischimpfung nicht
zugelassen ich gehe dabei aber davon aus
dass er das sein wird zu dem zeitpunkt
zu dem auffrischimpfungen landebahn
stehen also ich denke das ist eine
alternative
bevor wir auch da noch mal in die
details gehen gleich schauen wir erstmal
auf das prinzip wie dieser impfstoff
funktioniert und wie er sich
unterscheidet von den anderen eine kurze
zusammenfassung im bild
in der korona pandemie warten einige
ungeimpfte auf einen altbewährten
impfstoff türen oft als tot impfstoff
bezeichnet so ein impfstoff ist ja der
us firma nova wachs die ständige
impfkommission hat sich heute für einen
einsatz am 18 jahren ausgesprochen zwei
dosen im abstand von mindestens drei
wochen können dann zur
grundimmunisierung genutzt werden ab 21
februar sollen über wachs in deutschland
ausgeliefert werden
am 21 februar bekommen wir 1,4 millionen
dosen von nowaks und dann die woche
drauf also aus den neunten kalenderwoche
nochmal eine million damit kann man
schon arbeiten das geben wir das heißt
wir sie das gesundheitsministerium
gegeben dass ausschließlich an die
länder es geht nicht an die praxen und
die länder also können das dann nutzen
um die einrichtungs bezogene impfpflicht
sammer zu beschleunigen bei dem
impfstoff von nowaks handelt es sich um
ein protein basierten impfstoff
bestehend aus künstlich hergestellten
spike protein durch die impfung bildet
der körper antikörper und t-zellen gegen
diese proteine
neuartige m rna impfstoffe wie von
biotech und moderne sind etwas anders
sie enthalten keine abgeschwächten
krankheitserregern sondern eine art
bauanleitung damit baut sich der körper
spike proteine also teile des corona
virus es folgt eine dauerhafte eben nun
abwehr auch gegen das echte virus
weil m rna impfstoffe auf einen
neuartigen ansatz beruhen wünschen sich
viele menschen einen proteine im stoff
damit gibt es schon länger erfahrungen
etwa bei impfungen gegen die grippe
ist dass damit also wirklich dann eine
alternative dieses alte verfahren im
gegensatz zu mm stoffen
erklärt wurde dass das sogenannte anti
gehen also der stoff gegen den der
körper dann antikörper bildet ja direkt
durch die impfung zugeführt wird und
nicht im körper erst gebaut werden muss
ist da etwas ist eine definierte menge
und ein ja ein wirksames verfahren was
weiß man über nebenwirkungen bei diesem
verfahren
diesem verfahren beziehungsweise bei
diesem impfstoff dass es die
nebenwirkungen sind ja im stoff bezogen
es ist auch beim nova wachs impfstoff so
dass das ein relativ rea der impfstoff
ist also dass auch er bei einem größeren
anteil der menschen eine impfreaktion
erzeugt also ein 2 wenige tage nach der
impfung vor allen dingen schmerzen an
der einstichstelle oder dicke
lymphknoten unter dem geimpften arm oder
eben auch eine kurzzeitige
grippeähnliche symptome auflösung
auslösen kann darin unterscheidet er
sich in der tat nicht riesig von den
anderen problemstoffen sie haben ja
täglich mit menschen zu tun sie sind
allgemeinmedizinerin was hören sie wie
sehr wird dieser impfstoff als
alternative auch erwartet
ja ich höre schon von menschen die
darauf warten die sehr darauf hoffen die
sagen ich möchte mich bisher nicht
impfen lassen weil mir die verfahren des
amerikanisch stoffs oder auch die vector
impfstoffe die es dort gibt irgendwie
unheimlich waren so diese idee dass der
eigene körper den speck proteine
herstellt und mir ist es lieber wenn die
schweiz proteine im labor hergestellt
wurden und in einer klar definierten
menge daneben injiziert werden und
dadurch ein wirksamer impfschutz den
chip wie man das eben von anderen
stoffen auch schon kennt
es sind nicht so sehr viele menschen
aber es ist ein teil derer die bisher
skeptisch oder ängstlich waren die auf
diesen impfstoffen schauen wir mal auf
das impf der sport da kann man sehen wie
momentan die bereitschaft ist in
deutschland und da sehen wir
63,1 millionen menschen das sind 75,9
prozent der bevölkerung haben bisher
mindestens eine impfdosis erhalten
darunter gibt es auch die grafik da
sieht man das etwas besser hier dieser
dunkle balken das sind die die gepustet
sind 53,6 prozent vollständig geimpft
74,2 prozent und 75,9 prozent sind wie
gesagt mindestens einmal geimpft daneben
sehen wir die zahl die entsprechend sich
daraus ergibt
24,1 prozent sind nicht geimpft wobei
man dazu sagen muss hier unten die 4,8
prozent die dazugehören dass es die
altersgruppe für die es gar keinen
zugelassenen impfstoff gibt also die
null bis vierjährige
diese 24,1 prozent abzüglich der 4,8
also die knapp 20 prozent die gilt es ja
zu erreichen wie erreicht man die denn
aus ihrer überzeugung heraus frau
hungers ist das sozusagen jetzt mit
nowaks ein argument mehr dass sie haben
kein argument mehr ist es sicherlich und
ich hoffe sehr dass viele von diesen 20
prozent bisher skeptischen menschen sich
überzeugen lassen und dass sie doch das
vertrauen jetzt in diesen impfstoff
haben was sie vielleicht bisher in die
anderen impfstoffe nicht hatten und sich
somit entschließen sich impfen zu lassen
maßgeblich ist ja das stichwort ist
gefallen ist vertrauen einerseits
vertrauen in den staat oder eben der
zweifel am start dass man sagt ich
möchte das nicht das geht mir alles
soweit das kommt mir alles zu nahe und
das anderes vertrauen in den impfstoff
selbst bleiben wir erst mal beim start
hat der staat mit diesen impfstoffen mit
dem argument das ist ein anderer im
stoff der funktioniert ganz anders das
ist ein verfahren das es auch bei
anderen impfstoffen gibt ein argument
das glauben sie das wirklich überzeugt
oder sind es dann am ende die menschen
doch die sagen egal jetzt heißt es
anders aber ich will das einfach nicht
ich fürchte dass es auch die geben wird
und
sich vielleicht nicht alle überzeugen
lassen ich bin aber hoffnungsvoll dass
es doch viele sind
die das tun werden sie sagt merckx der
stadt ein argument die frage ist dann
wer ist denn eigentlich der staat der
staat sind wir alle
diesen impfstoff zugelassen haben
arzneimittelbehörden also fachleute die
auf basis der daten der hersteller
die impfstoffe bewerten die stiko
ist ebenfalls in dem sinne nicht der
staat sondern in ihren urteilen
unabhängig also unterliegt da keinerlei
weisung wir sind in unserer bewertung ja
zu dem schluss gekommen dass dies ein
empfehlenswerter impfstoff und ein
empfehlenswertes vorgehen ist und ja der
staat bittet oder fordert eben alle
menschen auf sich impfen zu lassen zu
ihrem eigenen schutz und eben auch zum
schutz derer um uns herum
bei denen die impfstoffe vielleicht aus
irgendeinem kunden grund nicht so gut
wirken oder die besonders gefährdet sind
und das bleibt ein sinnvolles vorgehen
mit nowaks im portfolio was heißt das
wiederum für die beratung versus
impfpflicht wenn man momentan auch davon
ausgeht das ist ja da stand noch ist es
freiwillig ist das ein argument mehr
dass aus ihrer perspektive heraus sticht
hilft dass und wie wichtig ist dabei
beratung
beratung ist immer wichtig weil
letztlich die entscheidung ja eine
persönliche entscheidung ist ein
eingriff an sich vornehmen zu lassen von
daher ist dieses vertrauen schaffen das
allerwichtigste
minister lauterbach hat ja vorhin schon
gesagt dass der impfstoff prioritär
einrichtungen des gesundheitswesens zur
verfügung gestellt werden soll das sind
ja diejenigen für die eine impfpflicht
schon gilt oder in kürze gelten wird und
die eben damit noch einmal die
möglichkeit bekommen sollen
wiemer dann doch eine in vogel anspruch
nehmen zu können und ich hoffe dass die
liefermengen ausreichend werden als dass
er eben auch an andere menschen gehen
kann die auf diesen impfstoffen oder ihn
akzeptieren würden schauen wir mal auf
den
schauen wir mal auf dem fortschritt nach
altersgruppen denn das ist ja auch
maßgeblich wenn es darum geht wie man
wie erreicht auch da sind wir wieder auf
der seite vom imf dashboard de
hier sehen wir bei den über 60-jährigen
waren schon 74,7 prozent beim boostern
und da haben wir eine impfquote von über
88 prozent bei den 18 bis 59 jährigen
und da sind wir vor allem bei den
berufstätigen sieht es deutlich anders
aus das sind gerade mal 56,4 prozent
gepustet und 82,2 prozent sind
vollständig geimpft bei den jüngeren das
lassen wir jetzt mal außen vor walter
nowak sowieso keine option ist diese
menschen zwischen 18 und 59 jahren ist
das sozusagen jetzt wichtig die
erreichen zu können mit nova wachsen und
gerade weil sie es wollen auch gesagt
haben es geht ja auch um menschen mit
ihm pflicht wenn es dann darum geht dass
das in den pflegeeinrichtungen oder
insgesamt in den
gesundheitseinrichtungen jetzt ab mitte
märz zur pflicht wird ist kennen sie
dass das darauf gewartet wird dass man
sagt mit nowaks fällt mir leichter ja
das kenne ich
das gibt mir gesagt menschen die im
gesundheitssystem arbeiten die genau
darauf hoffen und auf diesen impfstoff
gewartet haben denn nun eben da auch
noch rechtzeitig kommt und in der tat
ist es ganz wichtig dass die menschen in
dieser altersgruppe
ebenso wie vielleicht auch die älteren
die noch nicht geimpft sind die wenigen
älteren wirklich auch erreicht werden
und das hoffentlich für sich jetzt auch
so akzeptieren in rheinland pfalz gibt
es die homepage impfen punkt in
rheinland-pfalz punkt.de und da ist seit
montag letzter woche die möglichkeit
sich für nowaks registrieren zu lassen
wir haben nachgeschaut
12.700 sind es schon die sich sozusagen
schon für nowaks registrieren lassen das
heißt es muss ja eine gewisse
größenordnung menschen geben die jetzt
gar nicht mal aufgeklärt werden müssen
sondern die ihrerseits schon so viel
aufklärung betrieben haben und das
wirklich erwarten deckt das sich mit
ihren erfahrungen
das deckt sich insofern mit den
erfahrungen als das ja sehr viel
aufklärung werbung
drängen schon erfolgt ist sich mit den
vorhandenen impfstoffen also den inneren
allen stoffen vor allem oder eben auch
mit den vektor impfstoffen impfen zu
lassen und dass die menschen die sich
bisher dafür zu nicht entschließen
konnten
ja sich informiert haben bzw zumindest
für sich eine meinung haben eine meinung
gebildet haben und das ist ja generell
so dass wahrscheinlich noch nie in der
geschichte der impfstoff der menschheit
menschen sich so sehr über
herstellungsverfahren informiert haben
ich weiß nicht wer von ihnen über das
herstellungsverfahren des tetanus
impfstoffs oder das
grüßen impfstoffs oder was auch immer so
informiert ist aber zu kurz
zeiten war das ein thema auch in der
öffentlichkeit viele menschen wissen
darüber bescheid und haben dann eine
vorliebe und
in der tat ist es so dass die vorliebe
für einen klassisch traditionell
hergestellten protein impfstoff tod sind
die letztlich alle
warten oder sich dafür entschlossen
haben das ist diese menschen gibt und
die zahlen die sie gerade genannt haben
bestätigen das ja auch red bizeps fragt
über youtube für wen ist der navax
besonders geeignet für leute mit
immunschwäche
das kann man so nicht sagen es waren
leute mit ihm und sicher auch in den
zulassungsstudien drin das waren nicht
so furchtbar viele ich sag mal die
impfstoffe die jetzt schon besser
bewährt und besser bekannt sind und von
denen wir wissen dass sie wirklich
hervorragend wirken sind tatsächlich die
em-arena impfstoffe von daher wenn jetzt
jemand fragt welches ist der beste
impfstoff wenn ich
schwach bin dann würde ich wohl
antworten einem banalen stoff wenn man
denen dann aber dem nicht über den weg
traut oder den nicht möchte dann ist
mubaraks in der tat eine alternative und
das kann auch eine alternative für
menschen sein die so im wunschfach oder
immunsupprimierten sind dass sie auch
schon vorgenommen der impfungen nicht
reagiert haben also gar keine antikörper
gebildet haben das ist nicht furchtbar
häufig aber das gibt es und da war eben
bisher die empfehlung dann nochmal zu
impfen
und dass dieses noch mal impfen kann
eben jetzt alternativ auch mit dem
nowaks impfstoff erfolgen in der
hoffnung dass man dann damit eine
reaktion erzeugt das ist ein echter
zusatzbaustein kommen wir zum zweiten
beschluss der heute von der stiko
gefasst wurde sie befürworten jetzt den
sag mal zweiter booster als in der regel
die vierte impfung für besonders stark
gefährdete gruppen und beschäftigte im
gesundheits und pflegebereich warum
stichwort ist besonders gefährdete
gruppen
es ist so dass diese besonders
gefährdeten gruppen eben insbesondere
sehr betagte menschen sind oder menschen
mit bestimmten vorerkrankungen zum
beispiel mit dem und aggressionen oder
aber auch die die in besonderer weise
dem virus immer wieder begegnen ihm
nicht gut ausweichen können weil sie
eben beruflich exponiert sind und was
hinzukommt ist das her sinnvollerweise
diese menschen auch als erste geimpft
wurden das wären erstimpfung ist zum
teil vor einem jahr erfolgt mit der
entsprechenden zweitimpfung und die
erste booster impfung liegt bei vielen
dieser personen auch schon eine weile
zurück
und man weiß dass eben die
antikörper die immunantwort dann nach
einer weile wieder schwächer wird und
dass ein erneuter kontakt mit dem
sogenannten emv antigen also welches
protein egal ob vom körper selbst
hergestellt oder jetzt eben im impfstoff
vorhanden
diese immunantwort erstmal wieder an
schiebt und aufrecht und zumindest für
eine weile verbessert man weiß noch
nicht für ganz genau wie lange dann
dieser verbesserte schutz anhält aber in
der aktuellen phase wo sich ja sehr
viele menschen anstecken und sehr viele
menschen erkranken
bietet diese vierte impfung diesen
besonders gefährdeten menschen bei dem
gegen dritte im fach schon länger zurück
liegt eben noch mal ein stück weit einen
schutz auch das nochmal zum sortieren
welche erfahrungen haben sie da mit
israel gemacht da gibt es ja diese
vierte impfung schon länger und was hat
das für ihre empfehlung heute ausgemacht
ja wir haben die israelischen daten
angesehen die zeigen dass die wirte
impfung insbesondere der risikopersonen
eben einen einfluss hat auf die
krankheitshäufigkeit auf die häufigkeit
von sogenannten impf durchbrüchen also
einer erkrankung trotz
bereits bestehender impfungen auch trotz
bereits bestehender impfungen mit einer
ersten auffrischung und dass das eben
ein wirksames verfahren ist und
besonders gefährdete menschen persönlich
zu schützen und auch um ein stück weit
die
ja das weitertragen der infektion in der
bevölkerung zu bremsen man kriegt es
nicht ganz verhindert weil die
schutzwirkung nicht hundertprozentig ist
aber wann kann die übertragung ein
stückweit bremsen und das ist ja ganz
wichtig damit unser system nicht
überlastet wird wer ein booster hatte
und sich danach noch infiziert hat er
soll keinen zweiten booster erhalten
sagt die stiko und andererseits lese ich
hier nochmal die frage von peszko über
youtube macht es als genesener überhaupt
sinn sich noch impfen zu lassen
ja das ist ja eine infektion ist ja auch
eine auseinandersetzung
des körpers mit dem virus von daher
zählt dir ein stück weit mit als ein
ereignis was in die reihe der der
kontakte oder der instrument mit
eingerechnet wird wer jetzt früh
infiziert war dem ist ja schon lange
empfohlen sich dennoch impfen zu lassen
weil eben die frühen infektionen noch
die welt varianten waren die alpha
variante und weil dann dort auch eine
impfung den impfschutz verbessert
umgekehrt ist es tatsächlich ja so wer
jetzt nach bereits drei impfungen eine
erkrankung hatte ja der hat das vierte
ereignis sozusagen über die infektion
bekommen und wird aller
wahrscheinlichkeit nach mich davon
profitieren jetzt relativ zeitnah dann
auch noch eine impfung obendrauf zu
bekommen schauen wir abschließend noch
mal schnell auf das im dashboard nur um
auch eine entwicklung grundsätzlich zu
sehen wir sehen als es losging mit dem
impfen gab es ein hohes tempo bei den
erst und dann auch bei den zweit
impfungen aber seit september tut sich
da nicht viel es geht langsam hoch hier
oben diese kurve aber das ist kein
großer fortschritt mehr hier diese
dunkelblaue das ist das boostern das
ging steil nach oben
mitte dezember dann nochmal große zahlen
aber auch diese kurve flacht sich
langsam ab was sagen sie wenn jetzt die
vierte impfung auch noch kommt dann
fragen leute die fünfte sechste wo soll
das eigentlich hinführen kann können sie
verstehen dass auch eine impfmüdigkeit
kommt die sagen mein gott die fährte wo
soll das was soll da noch alles kommen
ich gehe im moment nicht davon aus dass
es zeitnah eine weitere empfehlung geben
wird das wird ein stück weit davon
abhängen ob es irgendwann impfstoffe
gibt regen die neueren varianten zb
spezifisch gegen romy grund zum einen
und zum zweiten ob es weitere varianten
gibt die sich von den ursprünglichen
soweit unterscheiden dass die ist ein
stadt gehabten impfungen und vielleicht
auch erkrankungen da schon wieder keine
wesentlichen schutz bieten das weiß man
letztlich nicht aber es wird ganz sicher
nicht so sein dass wir uns jetzt auf
alle ewigkeiten da alle drei bis sechs
monate wieder impfen lassen müssen aber
noch sind wir vielleicht auch alle an
dem ihn müde loch ist die pandemie ein
problem und noch infizieren sich viele
menschen und noch gibt es vor allen
dingen eben auch viele ungeimpfte und da
ist es eben weiterhin sinnvoll die
zahlen die sie gerade gezeigt haben in
der grafik bilden ja eben ab dass ich
anfangs viele menschen impfen lassen
wollten bis etwa juli gab es eine
priorisierung und es war gar nicht für
alle möglich und dann ist über den
sommer ja durften dann wirklich alle die
wollten und haben das auch getan und die
restliche das restliche viertel oder
fünftel der bevölkerung was übrig blieb
das sind eben diejenigen die
zweifeln oder angst haben oder dass
vielleicht für sich auch ganz klar
ablehnen und für die es sozusagen
eine alternative gibt frau professor
ewers vielen dank für die zeit und die
erklärung das was die stiko heute
sozusagen uns mitgegeben hat dass wir
das etwas besser verstanden haben und
hoffentlich die wesentlichen antworten
geben konnten danke nach ihnen zu ihnen
und danke ihnen für ihre aufmerksamkeit
für die fragen und fürs mitmachen und
bis bald und zum nächsten mal